hi hello everyone and thank you for
joining us today my name is Becky broto
and I'm a producer with quick-take by
Bloomberg and today I am joined by three
knee college students from Arizona State
University who created the web site is
my internship cancelled so I'm gonna let
them introduce themselves we have con
the V ash and on Anning tell me about
yourselves
hi I'm on an Aurora I'm a sophomore
majoring in computer science at Arizona
State University and I'm an incoming
software engineering intern at Apple hi
my name is Josh I'm a senior I'm gonna
be an interning software engineer at
American Express
hi I'm Khan I'm a computer science
student as well and graduating this may
as a senior that's great and thanks
again for for joining us and to those of
you watching this as you're joining the
conversation please comment with any
questions below and we'll be sure to ask
them so let's dive right in into your
into your project can you know on and I
can you please tell me how you first got
the idea to start a crowd-sourced
website for the summers internship
program sure so I got the idea from
basically I saw a lot of sources like a
a few github repositories a website
called candor a lot of other sources
where there was this like there were
these statuses for every company out
there and I saw this website called is
it canceled yeah calm which was a list
of events that were being canceled
around the United States and I mean all
across the world man
it had this nice look to it and we
thought that we can make a website that
has this name call is it K is my
internship cancelled dot-com and we
could have all these companies with
their logos and their statuses with
crowd-sourced data and also the other
sources it was hard to contribute to
them so we created an easy way for
people to contribute because it's not
just software engineers contributing to
it
it's
a bunch of people who were in management
finance political science but later on
as society developed we had edits and
unique features that are different than
other sources that are on the Internet
so we added two things one is the map
and the other is a comprehensive
verification process so I know that in
just a second I'm sure because it's
actually a pretty rigorous reporting and
verification process there that the
three of you are doing you're not just
reporting rumors right um so obviously
internships are at the forefront of your
minds as college students I was
wondering if you could tell me how many
internships programs you verified so far
I think we've probably verified around
25 to 30 programs as of now but the
remainder of the programs that aren't
officially verified necessarily are also
pretty sure to be legitimate because
we've received images from that
recruiters have sent these students
saying that the internship has been
cancelled or so on so considering those
as well I'd say we have over 250
internships with accurately reported
statuses on the website right now that's
amazing and for the ones that you verify
what's what's that process like
so we have our email addresses on the
website so we just tell recruiters and
representatives of these companies that
they can email us and update us with
their status so we've received a lot of
emails from various companies like we
were even in contact with Airbnb
recently regarding their internship
status so a lot of high profile
companies want to be properly
represented on this website because it's
almost a sort of accountability for
companies because when students see that
a company has canceled their internship
it's not the most positive image for
that company so companies and recruiters
from companies that are trying to
maintain their internship programs are
making an effort to appear as they're
still going with the internship as
remote at least so right and
when we've spoken before you mentioned
you know wanting to keep this project
going even beyond the summer and in that
regard have even connected with some
schools and obviously employers like you
just mentioned I think Deb yes you
mentioned publishing an open letter to
employers across the country could you
tell me about that yeah so the idea is
that so
internships are extremely important for
students and if they're getting
cancelled instead of being moved remote
that actually does hurt a lot of
students especially new grads so the
idea was to create an open letter to
send to companies you know basically
just talking about the reasons why
internships are important potentially
changing their changing position
although you know we'll see how that
actually goes through mm-hmm
on an a you mentioned the map yes sort
of gives you the the overview of where
these programs stand across the country
right so the map so with the map we're
actually pinpointing each company's
location so we can get an idea of where
each company like where the
cancellations are centered where the
remote ones are centered so it gives you
an idea of whether you know it you can
correlate this data with the coronavirus
cases in that area so in the san
francisco bay area as you can see there
are a lot of remote internships or
canceled internships mainly because a
lot of tech companies are also there so
there's gonna be a lot of companies
there as well but you can definitely
draw conclusions from the map itself
when you look at each company on a map
so this was actually suggested to me and
someone said this would be interesting
data to look at so that's why we created
the map yeah so now this data you can
collect and analyze and you can even I
guess write put out a report or show the
impact that the coronavirus has had on
these programs
right yeah um you know you mentioned
that your internships are still going
ahead as planned have they switched to
from
are you still expected to show up in
person what about you Khan okay so I'm
gonna be starting full-time in August in
New York City so as of now everything
seems to be going ahead as usual as
originally but of course so much is
uncertain about the future right now as
to whether New York's condition is going
to improve by then so I'm staying
connected with them and if needed it may
end up being a remote onboarding process
it's not really apparent right now but
as of now the company has reassured me
that it is continuing as expected
initially which I'm very happy for yeah
and if it is remote dev Yash could you
could you think of what some of those
challenges you might face working a
remote internship yeah definitely I
think one of the main things by an
internship is the social experiences
actually like having those you know team
meetings right just meeting a bunch of
people and you know just going around
the office knowing how it is to be in an
office environment so I think those are
the main impacts of having a remote
internship instead of a regular
internship also you know internship
programs they're not just working
generally speaking at least for text
tech in the tech industry for one of the
internship at least actually for my
internships like they have team builders
they have all sorts of activities to get
to add experience programs exactly
mentorships yeah you know you you
mentioned that you have heard from a lot
of employers right what is the response
overall been from from you know other
college students other people who are
looking for information on their
internships can you talk about that a
nanai yeah sure so I mean the website
since day one has been circling around
because first of all the name is kind of
stuck in people's heads but also because
you know there since we have an end to
and verification process since there's a
lot of accurate information and college
students want to know what's going on
with other internships and they want to
knew it know the truth the true picture
behind it
that's why they're trusting our website
to other sources because again we have
an end-to-end verification process which
involves a company recruiter sending us
an official email from their official
address and we don't trust any
screenshots yet we don't trust any
screenshot as official we always either
take official emails or press releases
or posts from a recruiter or company
representative on LinkedIn or other web
sites so we have these set of guidelines
that we were using to verify this and
another thing is that transparency so
each transparency and animated anonymity
so the thing is when this is informing
me yeah and the submit so anyone can
contribute to a website anonymously and
they can they have they fill out this
form and all the form responses that
were submitted are transparent so you
can go right now and see who submitted
what at what time and when when did we
add that to the main website so we go
over each submission where you know
there's a lot of data to look at when it
comes to this so it's very interesting
to college students especially people
who love to look at a lot of data who
love to analyze all that stuff to draw
conclusions on whether a certain
internship is going to be canceled or is
what's going to happen basically from
the volume of information that comes in
and I believe you mentioned that that
someone had actually found out about
their internship through their through
your website not even directly from her
yes yeah and definitely has like
expanded beyond what we anticipated it
like directly related to the question
that was asked like in terms of colleges
response to the website it's been quite
supportive many colleges and
universities across the United States
have actually linked to our website on
their career portal pages so they're
actively advertising this website as a
support platform for students who are
being impacted by internship
cancellations and certainly I know
several people whose internships have
been cancelled or even full-time
position
have been deferred for quite a while so
it is really impacting a lot of students
so we're hoping that this website can be
of help to them not only to understand
the environment right now but also look
for actively hiring opportunities or
replacement activities that they can do
for the summer or for the beginning of
their career so mm-hmm
so it's becoming a resource you're
working and helping people who are in
your situation now and who who knows
might be in this situation next year
right yes and speaking of that you know
the the future especially for for
employment in this country
you mentioned and of yash that your
graduating seniors right so tell me what
it feels like to know that you won't be
walking in a graduation ceremony this
year because of this pandemic yeah it's
definitely rough I'm pretty sure it's
rough for my parents my family who I
think really wanted to attend it we'll
see I might walk in December if that
happens otherwise I just might not oh
yeah it's not that's pretty much it like
critters suite yeah yeah yeah I think
we're fortunate that Arizona State
University is offering the opportunity
to participate in a later graduation in
person so I'll definitely take that up
because I'd like my family and friends
from across the United States to attend
my graduation and yeah like you said it
is an important moment in a college
students life or anyone's life so it's
unfortunate that we're not able to
participate in the traditional manner
but yeah but you know it's it's it's
obviously an unprecedented time across
the world right and being being so young
and at the beginning of your careers I
guess I was wondering if you know you're
going to be facing one of the worst job
markets in our country's history
how has the impact of the kovat 19
pandemic changed your attitude or
approach toward you know howyou jobs
searching for jobs or internships has it
changed that at all I think one aspect
that may have changed for the near term
is traditionally particularly
software engineering people have the
concept of job hopping very regularly in
order to move to a nicer team or get a
higher salary or a different location
and it's very common to job hop with
like to every one and a half to two
years which is very frequent compared to
other industries I think now people are
going to start becoming a bit more wary
of that and maybe appreciating the
stability that they have at their
current job and not risking
transitioning if the other company has
unexpected layoffs or issues that come
up I think that's one is the thing that
will change about the attitude towards
job search in the near term mm-hmm
definitely for you as well - yeah I mean
I have been lucky where you know I
haven't been hit by this but I know a
lot of people who have and you know it's
gonna be rough for them go graduating
just getting directly out of college
it's pretty difficult to get a job in
the first place because you don't have
experience usually that the first year
when you're out of college you're
considered new grads so you have a whole
bunch of opportunities directly for you
but if you miss out on those then
there's not really that many
alternatives to that afterwards mm-hmm
so the concern I guess would be that if
you can't make it into an internship or
a job this summer like what does that
mean for my future right
I'm sure exactly kids your age are
wondering that I would like to add
something to that
so I drink since a lot of internships
are being impacted it also impacts your
full-time jobs so the traditional so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about the
traditional method of least in software
engineering so basically in your junior
year you have companies approach you
junior year is the prime time we're
gonna you're gonna have a lot of
interviews from companies and if you get
an internship with a good company in
your junior year they're gonna convert
you to full-time so what companies are
basically looking for our new grads but
also like they want people people they
can groom and train right so if you have
an internship with that company before
there
if you do well at that internship that's
a way of them evaluating you for a
full-time job as well or training you
and once you're used to working at that
company you can simply you know
transition to full-time sign a full time
offer with them and that's how
traditional process but the thing is if
a lot of intricate are impacted it's
gonna be a problem for the people who
are graduating next year as well right
for long just hiring so it's hard for
them to just convert because they've
never done a internship before in the
first place so I have a question from
the audience have you noticed a trend
and the types of internship jobs or jobs
that are being cancelled is one industry
cancelling internships more than others
fine can you tell me about some with all
the data is showing sure so I think
primarily it's a matter of geography
like the regions that are most impacted
are canceling or moving internships to
remote more than others but of course
certain industries right now are being
impacted more than others one example
being the travel industry I mean
obviously people are not traveling
nearly as much as they used to be before
the pandemic began so inevitably these
companies are having to downsize their
internship programs or eliminate them
altogether because they just can't
afford to support that program
I mean internship programs at the end of
the day are a pathway to a new grad job
offer but they don't necessarily create
immediate value for the companies
because there's so much mentorship
mentorship that goes into it and so much
effort that goes into onboarding the
intern and within a period of three
months there's not really enough time to
onboard them have them have a
significant impact and then off board so
that's the reason why I think certain
industries are being affected more than
others yes so it used to be like this
internship was almost like an extended
job interview and now that's sort of
being uprooted completely I have another
audience question I'm gonna ask you on
an a you have been plans to expand the
website so right now we do have plans we
have
lot of companies willing to partner with
us for listing what who is hiring
so there yeah there's way up that
reached out to us that wanted to you
know partner with us so we're working
with a lot of partners like them that
are you know Blanche grew our list of
companies that are hiring and we're also
advocating more sources for that other
than that we're just implementing a
commenting system and a lot of other
things so that there's more engagement
there's more social engagement on the
website while also keeping it anonymous
mmm-hmm that people can you know voice
their opinions and if they think what if
there's some crowdsource data they can
come comment under the company itself so
that's a way to expand the website but
we're still thinking of great ways we're
taking suggestions for yeah and I did
see that you've even expanded
internationally a little bit at least on
the map seeing some programs out of
Europe so that's I guess that's also
even India so since I'm originally from
India I have connections to companies in
India as well I they reached out to me
and we added their name to the website
that's great sort of you know in terms
of final thoughts I would like you know
interview to tell me if you have any
advice for college students whose
internships have unfortunately been
cancelled the V ash maybe you can start
definitely I would say the main thing
you should do is look into doing micro
internships so those are really projects
that you do over the summer you work on
them full-time try to get them off the
ground because well you know one of the
biggest parts of an internship is the
fact that you're at least in software
engineering or you're building something
you're coding something I'm sure it's
relatively similar in different
industries like an MBA internship or
you're where you have certain roles so
if you can somehow get this experience
without a company you can definitely put
that on your resume and it would look
much better for you when you're looking
for a job
right almost like freelancing in a way
exactly and I would say definitely keep
an eye out on the internet for resources
that are coming up of course one of them
being is my internship cancel comm but
there's a bunch of other resources that
I'm personally seeing as well like on
LinkedIn I see finance companies saying
we're creating a month-long virtual
externship program for students that you
can just join into and register for and
learn about finance so in every industry
there are opportunities coming up and I
think in computer science we're lucky
enough that a lot of the work we do can
truly be done from home so a student
whose internship has unfortunately been
cancelled in software engineering can
just begin creating their own website
and then they'll be able to put that on
their resume and for the following
summer or whenever everything returns to
normal hopefully that will serve as some
evidence that this student is qualified
and experienced for other opportunities
so Canton sort of educating yourself
definitely freelance and on an a yeah
and to build upon that I think at least
in software engineering you can get a
lot of experience away by contributing
to open source projects so open source
projects for those who don't know there
as the word suggests it's open source
you can anyone can go ahead and
contribute to that and a company is
really value that because come when
you're working at a company a lot of
their code is already open source so if
you go to Facebook's github page you're
gonna find tons of open source software
that you can contribute to and maybe if
you do that you can list that on your
resume and that can know you liked an
internship at Facebook because you
worked on something that is used by
facebook.com so we're showing that you
can make a contribution to decipher so
that's the best part about software
engineering that anyone in the world can
contribute they don't necessarily
necessarily need to work at Facebook for
that
yeah or helpful for that just to
contribute what goes into making their
products because a lot of it is open to
the public
yeah well this was great thank you so
much for joining me Khan annonay and dev
Yash the Arizona State University
students who created the
site is my internship cancelled and
thank you for those of you at home who
watched us and submitted questions my
name is Becky brought to with quick-take
thank you see you next time thanks Becky
thank you